In the future, Europe will generate
more energy from the sea
The wind, waves, tides,
algae - and the sun
can produce clean renewable energy
This will help us reach
our 2030 climate targets
and make Europe
climate neutral by 2050
The EU is a global leader
in offshore renewable energies –
an area where we can
invest, grow, and export
our knowledge and products
to the rest of the world
The European Commission’s Offshore
Renewable Energy Strategy
protects the environment
and biodiversity
promotes sustainable
multi-use of the sea
increases the production
of clean and renewable energy
supports European industry
creates green jobs
#EUGreenDeal